[Music]  the ingredients in Singapore and in  Barcelona may be different when it comes  to social change but the role that  design can play in moving that forward I  think is in common so I found it  interesting that people across cultures  and geographies are able to correlate  with global problems and it's not very  difficult for them to understand where  we come from and what impact we are  trying to make to meet designers and  others views so service designers  without designers and to talk about them  in terms of how we could use inside to  make the world better place both of us  we are combining all design disciplines  to have an impact and I feel that  joining forces makes it possible to do  more we would like to continue to be the  connector between Barcelona and  Singapore which is really our role in  this exhibition because both can really  benefit from  [Music]  [Music]